buonasera a tutti questa sera vorrei
iniziare raccontandovi una storia è una
storia scritta 135 anni fa da edwin
abbott in piena epoca vittoriana
il titolo di questa storia è flatlandia
racconto fantastico a più dimensioni
protagonista di questa storia è neanche
il narratore è un quadrato che vive su
un foglio vive in un mondo
bidimensionale e questo foglio è
popolato da cerchi rette triangoli
oggetti bidimensionali la sera di
capodanno di fine millennio una sfera un
oggetto tridimensionale si rivela a
questo quadrato inizialmente il povero
quadrato che ha sempre solo conosciuto
un mondo 2d non riesce a vedere la sfera
nella terza dimensione
solo dopo tante vicissitudini
addirittura un viaggio nel mondo
tridimensionale della sfera il quadrato
finalmente riesce a percepire la terza
dimensione e prova quindi a convincere
gli abitanti di flatlandia che esiste
una terza dimensione
ma non viene creduto ed è imprigionato
allora il nostro amico quadrato scrive
un libro questo libro come memoir per
esortare i posteri a guardare sempre
oltre ciò che l'esperienza sensoriale ci
mostra ad immaginare oltre a cercare
oltre flatlandia c'è una frase molto
bella scritta dai sta in un libro nel
1931 che disse che l'immaginazione
abbraccia il mondo stimolando il
progresso facendo nascere l'evoluzione
questa frase è una frase effettivamente
importante è vera perché è proprio
grazie all'immaginazione che nel corso
dei secoli sono state fatte tante
scoperte che hanno portato a piccole e
grandi rivoluzioni scientifiche però non
dovremmo estrapolarla in maniera
eccessiva la conoscenza è sempre un
punto di partenza importantissimo
immaginiamo per un attimo
la nostra mente essere un razzo un razzo
che ambisce a mete irraggiungibili per
raggiungerle la nostra mente il razzo
deve fare un salto immaginativo uno
sforzo immaginativo enorme ma deve anche
poter partire da una solida base
riconoscenza quindi per progredire serve
l'intuizione di immaginazione
miscelate a conoscenza e metodo
sperimentale in un cocktail di difficile
equilibrio ed è proprio così che nel
corso dei secoli sono state fatte tante
scoperte che hanno permesso di rendere
visibile l'inimmaginabile come per
esempio quello che vediamo qui è un buco
nero solamente un mese fa è stata
spostata l'asticella del sapere un
pochino più in là
un team di scienziati a lavorando
lavorato alacremente per rendere
visibile l'invisibile è infatti quello
che ci troviamo a vedere è qualcosa che
non dovremmo neanche vedere un buco nero
è una regione dello spazio dove
l'attrazione gravitazionale è così
potente che nulla può sfuggire al suo
esterno neanche la luce non potremo
quindi neanche vederlo perché per vedere
qualcosa i nostri occhi devono essere
colpiti da radiazione luminosa ed eccoci
qui invece primi esseri umani in due
milioni di anni e mezzo ad osservare
questo meraviglioso corpo invisibile e
l'immagine che vediamo è un elaborazione
di dati radio dove la parte più
brillante del disco non sono altro che
polveri e gas che sono lì per essere
risucchiati da questo potentissimo
aspirapolvere
abbiamo spesso visto i buchi neri come
portali verso universi a più dimensioni
conosciamo benissimo il nostro mondo
tridimensionale
sappiamo di poterci muovere in tre
dimensioni sinistra destra avanti e
indietro su e giù
proviamo per un attimo ad immaginarsene
una quarta non è per niente facile vero
prima abbiamo sorriso alla difficoltà
del povero amico flat olandese
a immaginarsi una dimensione in più
andare da due dimensioni a tre
dimensioni ma anche per noi non è per
niente ovvio
proviamo con l'esercizio immaginativo
opposto proviamo per un attimo a
immaginarci un mondo a due dimensioni
prima io stessa per introdurlo ho detto
pensate ad un foglio ma un foglio è
bidimensionale
cos'è bidimensionale beh potremmo dire
che l'approssimazione e scientifica più
vicina è qualcosa che sia lungo e largo
ma spesso un solo atomo quindi un foglio
con lunghezza e larghezza ma lo spessore
di un singolo atomo
pensate che fino a 20 anni fa gli
scienziati pensavano e teorizzavano che
materiali bidimensionali non esistessero
fossero termodinamicamente instabile il
che vuol dire che una volta isolati
dalla controparte 3d si sarebbero a
riccio lati su se stessi diventando
quindi immediatamente 3d e invece ora
potete osservare dietro di me la foto di
due senza t russi che sono andati oltre
hanno immaginato
in realtà i materiali bidimensionali
potessero esistere el hanno comprovato e
per questo hanno vinto il premio nobel
per la fisica nel 2010 i due scienziati
all'epoca della scoperta erano un
professore andrè game e il suo studente
di dottorato costanti nuovo sell off e
il materiale in questione è il grafene
forse ne avrete sentito parlare cosa è
il grafene bella definizione più
semplice è che un singolo strato e di
grafite quindi per semplicità potremmo
dire che è lo strato costituente della
mina di una matita per fare una mina da
un millimetro servono 3 milioni di
strati di grafene impilati l'uno sopra
l'altro il gra fare ha insistito da
sempre ma è stato scoperto solamente nel
2004 ma pensate un po essendo la base
costituente di molti materiali a base
carbonio
già delle popolazioni dell'europa
sudorientale un circa 4000 anni fa
decoravano i vasi scrivendoli con la
grafite
se andassimo ad osservare con un
potentissimo microscopio questi vasi
andremo a vedere scopriremmo che in
realtà sono state sfogliate tanti
piccoli pezzettini di grafene
osserveremo il grafene e questo
grassanese sarebbe stato sfogliato un
qualcosa come 6 mila anni fa e lasciato
lì nel corso dei secoli per mostrarci
che non è poi così difficile isolare un
materiale bidimensionale
ed infatti è stato spesso detto che la
scoperta del grafene è stato un gioco da
ragazzi
come hanno scoperto dai menù rosa lo fa
il grafene beh un venerdì sera quando il
resto del mondo magari è fuori per un
aperitivo invece gli scienziati sono lì
in una stanza con il loro primo amore
che è l'assenza i due scienziati si
armano di nastro adesivo e grafite
mettono la grafite nel nastro adesivo e
iniziano ad e sfogliarla più e più volte
fino ad isolare tanti piccoli strati
spessi un singolo atomo tanti piccoli
strati di grafene vanno alla ricerca di
questi stati con potenti microscopi
perché badate bene il grafene è
praticamente invisibile assorbe solo il
2 per cento della luce visibile
e infatti se osservate queste immagini è
dietro di me è molto facile vedere
laddove la grafite diciamo è più spessa
mentre quei singoli strati di grafene
sono estremamente difficili da vedere
bisogna affinare la vista ma niente di
meno
loro li osservano di vedono e iniziano a
studiarne le proprietà che risultano
essere meraviglioso infatti da quel
giorno il grafene conosciuto come il
materiale delle meraviglie innanzitutto
all'interno del grafene le particelle di
carica si muovono a velocità
relativistiche si muovono così veloci
che immaginiamo esile come essere in un
auto da corsa che viaggiano su un
autostrada senza sassi nei buchi e
proprio perché viaggiano a queste
velocità prossima a quella della luce
quando isoliamo un pezzo di grafene fra
le nostre mani e lo facciamo ogni volta
che scriviamo con la matita per esempio
è come se avessimo un piccolo cern un
piccolo acceleratore di particelle fra
le mani perché abbiamo materiali dove le
particelle si muovono a velocità
relativistiche e questo ha permesso nel
corso degli anni agli scienziati di
comprovare una serie di teorie che erano
state postulate all'epoca di einstein e
che solo oggi possono trovare conferma e
quindi un vero e proprio parco giochi
per fisici
inoltre conducendo così bene
l'elettricità è possibile immaginare gli
dispositivi elettronici velocissimi
sottili e flessibili per esempio perché
grafene flessibile infatti una delle
caratteristiche straordinarie del
grafene un'altra è che il grafene unisce
flessibilità esistenza pensate un po e
flessibile come la classica e resistente
come il diamante possiamo manipolarlo
con una pinzetta un singolo strato di
atomi di carbonio senza danneggiarlo
forse il paragone più efficace è quello
della maga per gatti infatti è stato
calcolato che un metro quadro di grafene
quindi un'amaca spessa un atomo potrebbe
reggere un gatto è di 4 chili e
oltretutto il grafene e conduce molto
bene anche diciamo termicamente quindi
vuol dire che il gatto non si terrebbe
se ne starebbe ben comode un po come
dire che fra qualche anno vedremo
inizieremo a vedere stregati che
fluttuano nello spazio insomma oltre a
queste proprietà diciamo di
conducibilità elettrica termica
resistenza flessibilità perché queste
proprietà ce ne sono tante altre inizino
ad impattare la nostra vita perché il
grafene diventi un materiale che impatti
le nostre vite tutti i giorni
occorre trovare un modo per produrlo in
maniera scalabile quindi in grandi
quantità ed economicamente
pensate un po che con il metodo delle
spoliazioni di gainago sell off era
stimato che il grafene costasse circa
100 milioni di euro al centimetro quadro
il materiale più caro al mondo
ovviamente non c'è modo che un materiale
di questo tipo fini
all'interno di un prodotto e per rendere
quindi visibile un materiale invisibile
occorre fare questi passi in avanti a
livello tecnologico e fortunatamente
negli ultimi anni gli scienziati hanno
trovato modo per rendere il grafene
prodotto su larga scala e in maniera
economica
ed è proprio per questo che è diventato
un materiale e traslazionale che vuol
dire che è andato direttamente dai
laboratori di ricerca in prodotti
commerciali ed è infatti il 2018 è stato
l'anno in cui sono aumentati in maniera
esponenziale i prodotti a base grafene
avrete forse sentito parlare della
racchetta di djokovic una racchetta che
entrato a far parte della classifica
delle migliori 10 racchette grazie a
flessibilità è un buono swing e
maneggiabilità tutte proprietà che il
grafene permette di migliorare è
possibile fare caschi che sono più
sicuri e con i quali sisto di meno allo
stesso tempo esistono per esempio in
commercio e potete comprare telefonini
in quei circuiti di raffreddamento sono
fatti con il grafene e mentre abbiamo
già oggi giorno dei prodotti in cui il
grafene è importante e sensati intanto
stanno già lavorando oltre e cercano di
immaginarsi altri possibili utilizzi per
il grafene è stata da poco fatto un
brevetto in cui ha dimostrato che può
essere ricaricata la batteria di un
cellulare in soli 10 minuti grazie alla
batteria grafene inoltre essendo
flessibile potremmo immaginare schermi
che si piegano ed ancora potremmo avere
un miglioramento nella velocità di
trasmissione per esempio per il 5 g
potremmo utilizzare il grafene
nell'edilizia
una delle idee per esempio quella di
ricoprire i tetti con degli spray degli
inchiostri al grafene per fare dei
pannelli solari che rendano le nostre
abitazioni energeticamente indipendenti
ed eco compatibili
un'altra applicazione per esempio invece
è quella del biomedicale infatti è
possibile sviluppare dei sensori
estremamente sensibili che possono
diagnosticare una malattia negli stadi e
primitivi quando ancora non ci sono
altri tipi di
di sintomi e per esempio grazie a di
biomarker che possono essere rilevati da
liquidi corporei quali saliva urina con
piccoli sensori al grafene potrebbe
essere possibile un domani poter
semplicemente fare un check mattutino
per sapere se occorre fare un ulteriore
tipo di check più più approfondito
oppure tutto ok insomma un'altra cosa e
sono i viaggi in aereo i viaggi da in
aereo permettono promettono di poter
essere migliorati grazie al grafene
infatti sono stati già dimostrate delle
componenti di aerei e fatte con dei
composti a base grafene questi rendono
queste componenti più leggere quindi
l'aereo di fatto è più leggero e consuma
di meno ma non sono solamente i viaggi
in aereo che promettono di poter essere
modificati e migliorati dal grafene ma
anche quella sfida fantastica che
l'esplorazione dello spazio potrebbe
essere migliorata dal grafene c'è un
progetto bellissimo e progetto icarus
che è stato fatto nel 2010 da un gruppo
giapponese che ha portato delle vele
solari delle vele sottilissime
resistenti non ha il grafene fino a
venere solo grazie alla propulsione
solare
non c'è bisogno di carburante ma
solamente propulsione solare vuol dire
illuminazione del sole
il grafene un materiale ideale per la
propulsione solare è un materiale ideale
per fare bene perché a resistente e
flessibile e quindi siamo ancora lontani
ma chissà un domani potremmo scoprire un
qualche angolo dell'universo grazie a
vela il grafene ogni scoperta è un
viaggio d'andata meraviglioso che non
smette mai di arricchirci il viaggio nel
mondo del grafene è iniziato nel 2004
quando è stato scoperto per coincidenza
proprio quando è iniziata la mia
carriera accademica con un viaggio
d'andata per gli stati uniti per un
dottorato di ricerca che mi ha portato
ad amare ancora di più la scienza tante
scoperte sono state fatte grazie al
grafene ora gli scienziati stessi si
sono domandati se esiste un materiale
vedi perché non ne dovrebbero esistere
degli altri ed infatti da allora sono
stati scoperti tantissimi materiali 2 di
sempre con il metodo se vogliamo
scientificamente parlando poco ortodosso
delle spoliazioni tanti piccoli nano
mondi che promettono di modificare la
nostra esistenza ma tante di queste
scoperte
tanti di questi meravigliosi viaggi
d'andata non avranno mai un impatto
diretto sulle nostre vite ma ognuna di
loro contribuirà ad alimentare il sapere
umano a creare indirettamente progresso
in questo 2019 ancora non sappiamo se e
quanto il grafene impatterà le nostre
vite
se oltre a prodotti tecnologici quali
componenti elettroniche oppure prodotti
per l'abbigliamento
il grafene effettivamente si porterà ad
abitare in case più sicure ed eco
compatibili
oppure a viaggiare in aeree più leggeri
e che inquinano meno o ancora ad avere
cellulari super flessibile che viaggiano
velocemente si ricaricano in un attimo
tutto questo rimane ancora da vedere
quello che so di certo è che ci saranno
altre scoperte altri viaggi d'andata e
ci saranno viaggi di ritorno che
porteranno innovazione e progresso
noi in quanto esseri umani non
smetteremo mai di inseguire nuove idee
immaginare oltre di viaggiare oltre
flatlandia
[Applauso]